bonjour c'est bientôt les vacances alors
au grenier à sel nous avons concocté un
programme avec un bon paquet de films
nous avons nous allons commencer les
vacances avec kobo et l'armure magique
que nous conseillons à partir de 6 ans
cette même semaine nous aurons prendre
nounou avec les p'tits loups à partir de
3 ans et un programme de courts métrages
spécialement adaptés et nous avons aussi
radin pour un petit peu plus grands déjà
la semaine d'après nous avons ma vie de
courgettes c'est un film un peu
particulier puisque il y aura il est
programmé toute la sto qu'une semaine je
vais t'emmener dans son endroit avec
d'autres enfants comme toi sans papa et
sa maman je vous présente votre nouveau
camarade igga préfère qu'on l'appelle
courchesne est rentré chez moi mais il y
aura une séance le lundi 31 octobre une
un atelier bruitages c'est pour les
enfants à partir de 7 ans nous avons que
15 places pour cela il faut réserver au
01 30 69 84 62 vous contacter aurélie
le tarif est de 4 euros pour les moins
de 14 ans nous avons aussi cette semaine
là monsieur bout de bois ou un autre
programme de courts métrages pour les
petits que nous conseillons à partir de
3 ans et miss pérégrine pour un peu plus
grand à partir de 8 ans que nous aurons
un partant en vf et en vo sous-titrée
évidemment donc c'est le dernier film de
tim burton
je vous souhaite donc de bonnes vacances
et à bientôt au cinéma le grenier à sel